ja wenn wir schauen was Wladimir Putin
gerade so macht dann ist das erstaunlich
also er steht Atom U-Boote in die Nähe
von von Norwegen was macht Norwegen
Norwegen warnt was machen wir wir haben
Angst vor Atom U-Booten Vladimir Putin
drehte vor einigen Monaten Polen den
ölhandzug Polen wollte ohnehin
aussteigen was passiert bei uns wir
haben Angst vor kein Öl mehr also das
was er mir tut die Macht nennt man in
der in der in der Wissenschaft
reflexkontrolle Wladimir Putin weiß
genau welche Ängste in welchem Land
herrschen und also nimmt er das kleine
Hämmerchen Haut aus Knie und die
deutschen reagieren wie jedes Bein gehen
nach oben Aufregung ist da meine These
wir nehmen Vladimir Putin der einen
schrecklicher Kriegstreiber ist und ein
Bluthund ist und ein wirklicher schwerer
Verbrecher ist wir nehmen ihn aber in
seiner Stärke die ihr demonstriert und
in der Furcht ihr uns machen will viel
zu ernst es wird Zeit Wladimir Putin
auch seine reale Größe zu schrumpfen
dann machen wir das doch gleich mal hier
schrumpfen wir mal auf die reale Größe
du glaubst also er bleibt nur es ist
alles Teil seiner Propagandamaschinerie
du findest keine weitere Eskalation der
Kreml führt seit über 80-90 Jahren
psychologischen Krieg gegen den Westen
wir gehören zum Westen und er führt ihn
natürlich weiter auch nach 1990 Wladimir
Putin ist ein Geheimdienst Mann ist
umgeben von Geheimdienst Leuten in
Russland das ist wichtig für das
Verständnis dieses Staates hat die Silo
Wiki das sind Geheimdienst Leute und die
Mafia die haben den Staat übernommen das
ist im Prinzip die krempels die den
Start von innen nach außen die
Innenseite hat den Staat dort übernommen
und werde mir Putin weiß wie das
funktioniert und sein Apparat auch und
die machen sich größer als die
tatsächlich sind das Schlimme ist dass
er mir Putin an die scheingröße selber
glaubt hat und wirklich noch heute
glaubt er glaubt der tatsächlich er
könnte die gesamte Ukraine noch besetzen
der stört es ihn auch überhaupt nicht
dass das in seinen generalstoffchef sagt
Mensch genauso da bräuchten wir eine
Million Soldaten die haben wir nicht und
die Technik reicht auch nur noch ein
paar Monate die wieder hinten in der
Garage haben aber Wladimir Putin
Tod diese Drogen wird nach außen
getragen und da reicht es halt wenn
Atomwaffen viel eu-boote es sind ja
keine Atom bestückten U-Boote sind keine
Atomraketen drauf das sind U-Boote die
können diese Raketen tragen die lässt
man dann ins Eis mehr fahren die lässt
man von Norwegen wegen wegen Kreuz oder
schickt die mal kurz durch die durch die
Ostsee oder man fliegt mit
atomwaffenfähigen Bomben in die Nähe der
europäischen Grenze oder der NATO
Grenzen dann sind das Bomber die könnten
potentiell welche tragen sind als
Drohgebärde gemeint
konkrete Vorbereitung zu werden sondern
als Droge werde zu werden aus seiner
Sicht viele hat natürlich auch die
Befürchtung jetzt ist es um die
Waffenlieferung ging jetzt werden
weitere Waffen gefordert auch Kampfjets
und da kommt immer wieder ist Argument
oh das könnte zu einer Eskalation kommen
glaubst du dass das eine stringente
Argumentation ist oder glaubst du dass
es quasi nur in diesem Fall geht diesmal
ist es um aber man muss schon auch
schauen wie die weitere Entwicklung ist
welche Möglichkeiten hat dann Wladimir
da würde ich jetzt die NATO angreifen
Preisfrage womit da ist nicht mehr viel
da und wenn man dann über Waffen redet
die einer Kriegspartei zur Verfügung
gestellt werden die Rote Armee wäre im
Traum nicht bis Berlin gekommen ohne die
berühmte momentslinie da sind tausende
also mehr als 100.000 Fahrzeuge LKWs
Jeeps tausende von Lokomotiven tausende
von von Eisenbahnwaggons und fast
100.000 Panzer von den USA an Stadien
geliefert worden berlin ist nicht nur
mit russischen Panzern eingenommen
sondern vorwiegend mit amerikanischer
Technik die damals als Kriegshilfe
geliefert worden ist das ist im
momentsklinik kann man nachlesen sind
wunderbare zahlen das ist das berühmte
leih und übergabegesetz das man in den
USA genau für diese Fälle geschaffen hat
also die Rote Armee hätte es niemals
geschaffen das möchte
irgendwie sagt ja wir hätten die Technik
damals nicht annehmen sollen irgendwie
Angst die Sorge ganz real jetzt gerade
gab es ein friedensmanifest von der SAG
Wagenknecht und Alice Schwarzer das
bringt Peter schon zum Augenrollen aber
darin wird Julia Neigel schon gefürchtet
dass weitere Waffenlieferungen quasi in
einen dritten Weltkrieg münden können es
steht immer irgendwie im Raum auch in
ist wahrscheinlich auch zu werden ist
Grund für dieses Manifest ist das etwas
was Ihnen sorge bereitet
also mir macht das
keine Freude solche Diskussionen
überhaupt zu hören oder überhaupt solche
Nachrichten zu lesen weil ich ganz
wichtig finde so bin ich aufgewachsen
und ich halte es nach wie vor für
relevant und wesentlich dass wir
Friedenspolitik machen der
eskalationspolitik diplomatische
Gespräche anstreben beide Parteien
versuchen an einem Tisch zu bringen ich
bin nicht dabei ich kenne die die
Konflikte die auch schon vor dem vor dem
Einmarsch von einem von den Russen in
die Ukraine stattgefunden haben nicht
ist es eine ziemlich lange Geschichte
soweit ich weiß ist die schon 2014
losgegangen und hat auch früher und ich
persönlich mache mir nicht an wirklich
alle Details zu kennen das heißt ich
kenne die Wahrheit nicht und ich hielt
es für wichtig das ist auch die Aufgabe
meiner Auffassung nach der
Bundesrepublik Deutschland für
Friedenspolitik zu sagen ich halte es
nicht für klug noch Waffen da
reinzuhauen weil es nämlich einfach den
Krieg verlängert und eine
Friedenspolitik noch komplizierter macht
wir sollten eigentlich unsere Aufgabe
erfüllen die nach dem zweiten Welt
Weltkrieg in unserer Hände gelegt worden
ist dass wir eben Friedenspolitik
diplomatische und die eskalationspolitik
betreiben bei militäremotional ist die
Argumentation von Frau Neigel natürlich
nachvollziehbar aber wie real politisch
ist sie auch wie sehen Sie das ich kann
nicht einschätzen ich verstehe beide
Argumente beide Seiten ich bin wirklich
militärisch Projekt aufgewachsen war
acht Jahre bei der Bundeswehr
Fallschirmjäger und Panzergrenadier also
ich weiß um was für Technik ist da geht
ich kenne die ganz genau ich kann das
nicht beurteilen ob die U-Boote mit
Atomwaffen bestückt sind oder nicht das
weiß ich alles nicht aber ich habe
trotzdem Angst ich sag ganz ehrlich ich
bin sehr pro militärisch eingestellt ich
habe trotzdem Angst vor diesem Krieg und
ich sehe momentan ich finde es
vollkommen richtig der Ukraine zu helfen
ganz klar ja auch Waffenlieferung ja bis
zum gewissen Punkt ja aber was folgt
denn wo ist das Ende wo ist die
Diplomatie und da bin ich voll bei ihm
und ich weiß das Argument kommt jetzt
mit Putin kann man nicht reden das hört
jedes Mal man muss auch diesen
schlechten Menschen irgendetwas liegen
wie ja was kommt denn so können wir doch
wir können ja klar
wir haben in der Ukraine krieg ja und
den führt einer und es gibt
Verhandlungen die die damals liefen und
die einer aufgegeben hat und das der
Mann heißt
Verhandlungen dabei entschuldigung es
gibt es gab in Weißrussland
fahrverhandlung lesen Sie es nach es gab
Verhandlung in Weißrussland es gab die
in der Türkei die hat Russland verlassen
das ist ja nun wirklich nicht ist kein
geheimwerk das ist publik es gab diese
Frage Moment Krieg gegen Russland nein
die NATO kann kein Krieg führen und zwar
einmal einfachen Grund und den bitte ich
einfach schlicht unter greifend auch an
diesen Rändern einmal zur Kenntnis zu
nehmen die NATO ist ein
Verteidigungsbündnis die NATO kann nicht
angreifen das ist nicht möglich nein die
kann nicht angreifen und der Rest ist
Propaganda wirklich und aber aller
schlimmsten aber nein lassen
das ist auf dem doch das ist Propaganda
das ist schlichte Propaganda da fallen
sie wirklich auf Propaganda rein the
diplomatische Lösung ja dann gehen sie
doch zu Herrn Putin gehen Sie doch mal
auf den Roten Platz und versuchen Sie
ein Schild hochzuhalten wir sind für
eine diplomatische Lösung im Krieg gegen
betreiben sie Moment nein warten sie
reden von einem ganz einfache Frage den
Bereich in Deutschland befreit
ich ich möchte dass ich die Leute die
das Wagenknecht und schwarzer Papier
unterschrieben haben mit einem Schild
auf den Roten Platz stellen und fordern
ein Ende und eine diplomatische Lösung
im Krieg gegen die Ukraine wissen Sie
was den passiert die sind keine zwei
Minuten da und dann sind die verhaftet
und ich war vier Wochen lang die ersten
Kriegswochen war ich in Russland ich
habe gesehen wie eine Frau weißen blauen
Mantel und eine gelbe Hose getragen hat
von der Straße weg worden ist
ich habe am 23 februar abends die
Invasionsarmee gefilmt wie sie in die
Ukraine reingefahren ist und ich kenne
die steht in der Ukraine reagiert worden
sind und den zu sagen wären sie nicht
mal mit zum kurzen Rock in den Park
gegangen und hat sich die unter was
stellt man was eure Lösung ich möchte
immer wissen jetzt die Lösung kann nur
sein dass man die Ukraine so ausstattet
dass sie den dass sie den Krieg auf
ihrem Territorium gewinnen kann oder
Vladimir Putin kommt zu Verhandlung aber
wladimir Putin hat als Bedingung für
Verhandlungen gesetzt dass er die
Ostukraine behalten darf und das kann
doch wohl nicht wahr sein seit wann darf
der der angreift den Frieden diktieren
wann Frieden ist wann der Krieg zu Ende
ist das bestimmt die Ukraine und wenn
ich auch bin ich auch bei ihnen aber es
musste auch in unserem Interesse sein
diesen Krieg wirklich schnell zu beenden
wo ich mich auskenne ich weiß wie viel
Weizen aus dieser aus dieser Region
rauskommt über ein dritte des weltweiten
Weizen kommt raus gut jeder zehnte
Mensch leidet akut Hunger und wenn Sie
je länger dieser kriegen
die Lösung muss doch irgendwann schnell
diplomatische Lösungen
Kreml unterfrage meine Aufgabe ist auch
nicht als Außendienst zu sagen
aber das hat einfach den Krieg nicht
ausgelöst und das beendet auch keinen
Krieg den Krieg kann nur einer beenden
nämlich der Mann
hingehen den deutschen sagen wir müssen
sie abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie